hey everyone it's Mike about OSA and
welcome to the Oder flows market
analysis for August 18 2017 it's
actually Friday morning it's about 9:00
in the morning a little bit after 9:00
now but I'm recording this because I'm
not sure they'll do one a bit later if I
can I will but you know it's kind of a
crazy week again you know I didn't think
things would get more crazy than last
week but they did this week
you made a decent sell-off yesterday
we're down about one and a quarter
percent but you know I hardly call it a
crash or anything like that you know
that these Doomsday's you know these
people so anti-trump on TV that the
markets going down one percent and they
think it's the end of the world already
but anyway get through a brief
disclaimer here this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures train
contain substantial risk and it's not
for every investor and investor could
potentially lose all on more than the
initial investment risk capitals money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results again very
important line only risk capital should
be used for training and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading now not everybody is cut out to
be a trader and you know as blunt as
that sounds it's it's the truth you know
as I've been around trading for my
entire professional career you know 20
years and you know as I've seen people
come in you know very cocky and then
blow up and then you know that's it you
know they think trading is the way the
easy money and it's honestly it's not
you know the the ones that are most
successful are the ones that really
apply themselves and never stop learning
you know basically you know people ask
what's the difference between a
successful trader and a losing trader
well you know it takes dedication it
takes seriousness and it takes desire
right you know notice the ones that fail
think they know everything whereas the
ones that succeed comment you know you
think you know they say I know that they
don't know everything okay so
that's why I do these videos is you know
I try to teach you know some of what
I've learned over the years you know
maybe something will connect with you
that you'll say yeah now I can
understand that a bit more and you know
thanks Mike for pointing that out
you know that's all you know I'm not
doing it because you know some kind of
put myself out there as some guru no I'm
just trying to share the knowledge that
I've acquired over the years and you
know hopefully you know you can you can
learn something and use it in your
trading so the tools I use in this
presentation are the order flow trader
which is the volume footprint chart and
the Delta scalper now you know the order
flows trader software right it's it's
not a cheap software it sells for around
$1,000 and you know it's a one-time fee
so it's not like I'll be charging you
every month or anything like that but
you know from footprint charts you do
have a lot of choices and one of the
things that makes mine different is
because you know my software plots out
certain things you know plots out these
ratios I case you want to know what
these numbers are these are you know my
order flows traders ratio so it's
telling me there's either price
rejection or price resistance or price
support that I don't have it on here but
you know if it's a blue number something
to watch if it's a black number it's
just your normal order flow and why is
that important because like you know I
talk about these things in almost every
video so I call a divergence and ratio
ratio on divergence so at a low you got
a divergence you got the positive Delta
look for a blue number here the ratio if
it's not in the ratio if it's not in the
bar with the low look to the next bar
okay so here you got the divergence and
the next bar you got the ratio that's a
bullish sign add to it you got to dot
the scalper here telling you things are
changing in the Delta that is it's
picking up this is the Delta here right
it's a net difference between buyers and
sellers aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar and it picks up shifts
in supply and demand so this market was
supply driven right that's what we're
going lower because a lot of supply now
demand is coming into the market is
picked up in the Delta scalper and what
happens is if you rally you have a nice
4-point rally here this is at 3:00 in
the morning 4:00 in the morning so you
got your
divergence in your ratio and y'all Scott
and Delta scalper you got a nice little
rally going here now you know a little
bit later you got Delta scalper this one
didn't work you know that one failed
then you know later cash session opened
8:30 Chicago time right here you got a
lot of volume coming in you got another
ratio and divergence here right on the
low I remember looking at this thinking
hey this is it maybe if you get a bit of
a rally what happens next bar you got a
bullish ratio nice positive Delta hey
that's great
okay let's just step through it here
next bar this is not a good sign here
now you got a bearish ratio so you got
some stopping volume coming up here
around twenty four twenty six and a half
twenty four twenty six and
three-quarters is the opening price and
if it markets kind of direction let's go
we're going to hang around the opening
price but it's not good sign that you
got negative Delta you what you want to
see if you're going to pull away from
this low is a nice positive Delta so
you're not seeing that yet then here
okay seven hundred okay maybe yeah maybe
that's good we can finally start to
rally and I'll [__] another four hundred
and what more importantly what's
happening corner controls in these bars
right around the same levels so you know
our value areas is kind of forming in
here right now then you get this bar
yeah I poke slower but it comes back
back up comes right back up to that
twenty six area then boom this one this
bar kissa death - mm Delta is very
negative to be getting that off the low
because you know if you're going to move
off the low you don't want selling to
come back in and 2209 is quite strong
especially on a four range bar and what
happens boom bottom just falls out make
new lows you get another failed so this
ratio and divergence doesn't work out
but you could pick it up by you get
timing as bar you you know it's not
working and then seeing the strong
negative Delta you know just forget
about a stick before you know take your
loss on the trade you know if you could
scratch it great but you know don't be
afraid to take that loss then we just
sort of go sideways sideways sideways
then boom poke low or break out through
the new lows here a nice text on a
balance as you're taking off the lows
and then you get down here too
these new lows and you just sort of
hanging around here now you got the
Delta scalper give it a bike it's kind
of a short-lived little rally there down
into new lows here you got a couple
failed divergences boom boom that fail
you make that new low here at 8:58 just
before nine o'clock you know we are
getting this a little bit of a rally
here but when we were Alan back up
towards is the opening price and what do
we do we hit the opening price area we
got some price rejection in this you can
see it in this ratio here fifty one
point nine seven and we just started
come off a little bit from there which
sort of puts us at where we're at right
now
now the other market I thought was
interesting today was the bonds as well
let me just get my bond chart here okay
so where we train right now right now
back at 150 602 but earlier in the day
again right off the low ratio and
divergence I talk about these things
every day people right secondly talking
about it but again you know if you just
buy the software and you just look for
these ratio on divergences then you know
that I don't say that's all you need but
that will put you ahead of a lot of
people that aren't aren't using this
information you know it reads the order
flow and puts out the ratio there based
on the order flow then later on 8:09 got
the delta scalper giving you a bye and
your rally up from you know the o2 area
all the way up to the 12 area got a
bearish ratio up here you got small
positive Delta 68 you know we've sort of
come off a little bit this is the o2x
trade right when you get a bearish ratio
look for a pullback within a couple of
ticks of the high you got it here within
one tick and then a sell off right this
is the why they call do 2x is because oh
you put a circle around it you put a
limit to ticks away from the high here
and X is zero
x marks the spot so euro to X that's
euro to X trade right there okay so this
next chart I'll show you this is add
axis is the Delta scalper now you know
the Delta scalper again it's an order
full tool but it'll work on a normal bar
chart because you know I realize not
everybody is into order flow but you
know if you can use the Delta scalper in
your trading on a normal bar chart say
you have an it right so you have your
own levels that you like to trade around
you know try it with a delta scalper and
it's quite powerful but anyway this is
just a normal plain bar chart or a
candlestick chart you run in the Delta
scalper and this is the dax okay now
this the settings are twenty one one two
five two now there's you know the
default settings that I normally use our
seven one two five two I'm going to walk
you through both charts just to sort of
show you so anyway twenty will get less
signals then seven it'll taken more more
previous bars into the into the equation
but anyway you know what I want to talk
about here is look at this okay so this
is a Dax this morning so you get a cell
here right 21:12 one thirty and all the
way down to 100 you know get a bite it
fails a couple buys here that fail okay
because it gets topped out you take some
small losses here small loss here then
boom twenty down back down to you know I
don't know what this is ninety okay
so you know then we get another small
trade here another nice big trade here
from ninety all the way up I don't know
where you would have gotten out here but
say you held it all way to the next
signal at 150 so you're getting a cash I
know what this was a thirty you call
thirty points here another thirty points
here thirty sixty points and then
another sixty points here you know so
it's reading over 100 points
one hundred and twenty points you had a
few small losses maybe five eight ten
ticks at the max on these that you lost
but if you're getting you know if you
you know five to eight ticks but you're
getting back you know 30 ticks on a
trade then you know that's the good risk
reward that you want right and then here
you get another you know you short at
155 150 or whatever all the way down to
130 we get to buy and then back from 130
all the way back up to 160 you know so
you get another I don't know what that
is another 50 ticks there this one
didn't work out and you know it's not
about having every trade being the
winner right it's having the risk reward
ratio in line right you're risking a
small small amount all right like this
right you say you're getting along here
you're going nowhere you're just risking
this this little bit right here to catch
a move like this all right that's what
you want so again you know I don't want
people saying well you only show one or
chart that looks good on this is the
other chart you know the reason why I
use 20 I keep a 20 open and I keep the 7
open it is specifically to show people
what the difference looks like with the
20 you're going to get less signals then
you're going to get with the 7 7 is the
default setting which I use in pretty
much every market but again you know
going back here you know you're getting
you still don't get the same signals you
just gonna get a bit more you know so
the big obvious difference was you know
on the 20 you're not getting this this
next trade here right at what time is at
7:40 so from 160 all the way down to
excuse me on starting the clock again
130 and you don't get that one here it's
not there but you know the default
settings are probably good enough but
again if you want to get going to sort
of clean out some of your trade some of
your losing trades like this you know go
with a larger larger number instead of 7
okay so that's the DAX um I don't know
another chart I could pop up here real
quick EEMA nice what is this 987 tick
chart with the Delta scalper this
morning well you get move here move
there short here get short there along
there
you know a little move here and getting
this buyer sort of back to break even
right now I know some people gonna say
all you didn't give me a cell here
it sucks well it you know the Delta
didn't you know what was happening up
here wasn't obvious in the Delta so you
know that's why there's no signal but
when you got a move here here here here
here it was obvious again it's not about
picking every single turning point but
you know it's pretty good at picking
some of the major turning points now as
a Dow is a hundred tick chart you know
in that's pretty tight chart and going
back to this morning you got a cell here
cell here a buy here a cell here this
buy sell buy a couple buys and buy a
fails a cell you know puts us back we're
over here along 9:20 this morning right
now you know Japanese yen five-minute
chart of the Katori nice-looking
Japanese in chart this morning a little
bit of movement here a little bit here a
nice rally from 7:00 in the morning 90
I live up to 92 you know why 10:15
curious what the euro currency looks
like I forgot to ready let me see if I
could find the chart euro 5 minutes
okay is the euro chart here I mean look
at this
you know it's giving you a buy one 1750
right before the big rally then sell-off
but say you just buy it here and you get
out here you know somewhere in here
that's a decent move I think here you
run into some trouble but you know
hopefully you could have got something
out of this early move in the morning so
anyway again it's still a little bit
early in the day it's only 9 23 right
now we'll see how this this day ends up
if I can I'll try to record another
video late in the later no promises but
it all depends on time permitting and
and everything but hopefully I'll try
and get one out a little bit later today
for everybody so thanks for watching
this and find out more go to order flows
calm or go to Delta scalper calm thanks
everyone
bye-bye